[Music]
first perfect score of the season set it
like it still and it's the moment it
happened every time we look at each
other we go oh my god oh my god it was
pretty crazy and it's pretty cool
because this is the I've never gotten
the first perfect score of any season
that I've been on so this is a first for
both of us and it's really cool that we
get to have that together because it's a
big thing
[Music]
these are the front-runners do you feel
that the end of the day everybody's
journeys different and I personally
Lindsey's goal our goal as partners are
to get better every week that's the
ultimate goal and thus far we have
managed to get a better score every week
and though honestly like getting the
first perfect score is insanely amazing
but it also is it puts a lot of pressure
on us because now there's there's not a
better score than that but there are a
lot of worse scores and we're gonna be
we're not gonna want that to happen so
to go so hopefully we stay hopefully
America votes for us and keeps us on the
show our goal is to hopefully get more
of those
[Music]
you